bbc was reporting on the french open
today when they ran this clip
and it's one step closer to reaching
week two of a grand slam viewers will
notice the ticket declaring manchester
united are rubbish and weather rain
everywhere two pretty accurate
statements to be honest but they
nonetheless did one of their handwriting
apologies
someone was training to learn how to
to use the ticker and to put text on the
ticker so they were just writing random
things not in in earnest and um that
comment appeared so apologies if you saw
that and you were offended and you're a
fan of manchester united but certainly
that was you know a mistake
relax i wasn't remotely offended it does
rain all the time in manchester and
united
are rubbish right now cristiano ronaldo
accepted
the bbc should just employ people to do
their jobs better we'd never make a
mistake like that here
the last few minutes breaking news has
been on the papers on the websites that
meghan markle for reasons that i find
completely baffling has turned up at the
scene of the mass shooting in america
right in texas
to put flowers down
veldy i don't know why she's there and i
could have asked once you're now angry
with her for visiting this fight i don't
know what she's doing but confused i'm
confused was she lost she flew all the
way to texas she threw all the way to
texas it seems to ladies my question is
this esther
i don't know what she's doing there
other than it seems self-promoting
and if the netflix cameras are following
her to do something like this i would
find that unbelievably distasteful yeah
listen i would like to give her the
benefit of the doubt just because you
know this is this is a tragedy that has
moved everyone that she's not doing this
um as a form of self-promotion however
if there are cameras if they're netflix
cameras then clearly she is influencer
trainee lawyer reality style global
irritant kim kardashian can now add
vegan food ambassador to her list of
supposed accomplishments she's filmed
this cringe making ad for meatless
burger brand beyond meat but i noticed
something that made me rather suspicious
take a look
i believe so much in the mission of
beyond meat that i've stepped in to help
with my greatest asset my taste
this plant-based meat is not only
amazingly delicious but it's also better
for you and better for the planet
yeah
the problem is if you watch really
carefully
she never puts any of it into her mouth
i've rumbled you kim kardashian have you
ever actually eaten that vegan gruel are
you just taking the cash it's tough work
being a toddler always hungry learning
the cruel constant hiccups and of course
dealing with unconscious racial buyers
yeah apparently uh babies are racist
that's according to an educational
poster shared by labour run london
council it says that at three months
babies already look more at faces that
match the race of their caregivers the
title says children are never too young
to talk about race well you know what
they sometimes are too young to talk
about race babies aren't racist i've had
four of them
leave the babies alone this little kid
alberto cartuccia chengalani from
central italy who decided to take up
piano
he's five
and he plays mozart like this
[Music]
i mean the only thing i would say in
criticism is apparently it was known as
the sonata
or sonata
meaning it was the simple sonata and i
think we can all agree i'm a bit of a
pianist that is quite a straightforward
sonata if you know what you're doing uh
five years old
alberto way to go i think we should look
out for that guy he's going to go far
good evening everyone
i'm joan collins and i am going to be
completely uncensored tonight
giles i'll have my drink now
so
cheers
roll the titles